Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
February 8th,
2016 what's going on everybody?
Huh?
All my darling.
Oh Mama Darlin Darlin,
Denver,
Colorado.
Bunchy head please.
And some miners and the one so both trophy.
Um,
congratulations to everybody in rocky,
Matt and hat kind of Ratto Keenan fuck and cows and Stinky Greeley,
Greeley,
Colorado.
Man.
If you ever want to know,
you know what a bunch of murdered cows smell like for the next time you eat a
burger,
I suggest you go there on a bad smell day as where they call it bad smell date.
And then you call up the slaughterhouse.
He like,
Hey,
could you fucking,
uh,
could you fucking tone it down a little?
You know,
the wind's blowing down to my house.
Why don't you lay off killing those fucking cows?
You know,
not saying,
I know luck.
Bert,
I'm here in San Francisco and all of those limousine liberals out in Hollywood,
um,
out there eating them fucking Tofu patties.
You know,
that shit causes cancer,
don't you?
The fuck is a Tofu.
I'm sorry.
Congratulations to the Denver Broncos.
And guess what?
All Billy bread face.
He wanted a little bit of money but none of the old,
the old man yo man Mu River.
I'm
sorry.
I'm very happy for a Peyton manning man.
I though I just,
I didn't want to see him go in there and get his fucking ass kicked and I won't,
I know what you guys are thinking.
Hey Bill,
why did you bet on the Broncos?
You didn't say shit predicting one way or the other?
Um,
I didn't have,
I didn't have any feeling one way or the other on the uh,
on the game.
I thought what a lot of people thought.
I just thought the fucking panthers were going to,
if they got up early it was going to get ugly and uh,
I dunno,
but then just everybody was saying it,
everybody kept fucking saying it.
You know,
do the pant is going to be a fucking game.
Right?
Everyone was just saying that the panthers were going to fucking destroy.
They went,
went by 17 two,
it's going to be 17 not to buy any of the first quarter.
This is what all my friends was saying.
So I came up with this quick theory because I wanted to put money on the game,
you know,
cause my team wasn't in it and I wasn't really excited about it.
So I figured I,
well,
if everybody's saying the panthers though,
right?
How does Vegas make any money?
The only way Vegas makes monies is if the Broncos win.
Vegas always has the lights on.
Even during the day,
they never shut them off.
They got the AC on what the fucking doors open.
And I don't see anybody concerned out there,
right,
is they're making money.
So I said,
fuck it.
I'm going to go against the grain.
I didn't even take the points.
I just bet it.
I bet the line 100 and make one 90 through 100 bucks on it.
And
they,
Jesus Christ,
I guess that Denver Broncos' defense was,
was as good as they were saying.
I just thought like,
I thought we made them look better than they work as our offensive line was
fucking beat up.
But,
um,
I don't know if you noticed the entire time when the Broncos beat the Patriots,
at no point was Tom Brady comfortable.
He wasn't screaming and yelling,
no,
whatever the fuck he yelled,
sit as receivers
supposed to be a post pattern,
right?
Whatever the fuck it is,
he yells at them.
He didn't do that.
Once he had his eyebrows down and he looked fucking uncomfortable.
He felt people at his feet the whole fucking game.
They never felt comfortable.
And,
um,
you know,
von Miller would do that little fucking little,
the little I'm,
I'm,
I'm going this way.
Oh No,
I'm not.
And the guy fell for it every fucking time on the Patriots,
right?
And I'm thinking like,
Jesus Christ,
how much does that dude on the Patriots stink that he keeps falling for that?
And Lo and behold,
I watched von Miller do it all game against Carolina Panthers.
If he,
I don't know if you notice this,
there's a lot of stats.
How many times did you see Cam Newton celebrate?
I got to,
I,
as far as I can remember,
zero.
He didn't do one of those little first down fucking point things.
Eating,
not one kid got a ball,
he never fucking ripped off or enough is soap to show the superman s underneath,
you know,
diarrhea.
You didn't see that watch Cam Newton had zero fun.
In fact,
if I remember correctly,
because I had a lot of Budweiser's um,
I probably drank as many.
Budweiser's is fucking Peyton manning said he was going to drink by the fourth
quarter.
The only thing I remember Cam Newton doing was fallen down when they miss the
fucking,
uh,
when they miss that,
that field goal attempt,
it just wasn't their fucking day,
but he got mugged
five mil,
a kid.
Just see,
just give me that fucking ball.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's not like fucking Lyman run an after like a bunch of crazy dogs or whatever
of that classic NFL quote goes.
That was just complete fucking domination by the Denver Broncos' defense.
Uh,
to the point,
I think Peyton manning only had about 40 more yards passing than I did.
But you know what,
when it counted,
he got it done.
So,
uh,
congratulations to them.
And I actually,
I went against everything that I said.
I not only,
I didn't take the game,
I forgot to tape it like a fucking asshole.
And I went to a Superbowl party,
which I always say I'm not going,
you know,
cause there's always 50 fucking people there and only like,
12 of them give a shit about the game and everybody else who's running around in
the oil,
all the fucking shit that I fucking had a tampon
up my ass above for fucking ever foot those things.
But I actually said,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm going to go to a party cause you know,
I'm just not into the fucking game or whatever.
And then I showed up and I realized that was totally into the game.
And fortunately the party I went to,
it was great.
Everybody was into it.
Everybody was watching,
people were saying stuff about the game that made sense.
You know,
it was football fans and the food was fucking tremendous.
And um,
had a great time.
I got to tell you,
go into the Super Bowl party though.
Uh,
something that I never noticed was,
uh,
the just general open hatred for Coldplay.
Why does everybody hate called there?
Why does everybody hate that bed?
They're not that bad.
Right?
Everybody's Artaud is so fucking lame.
They get like,
they get like half,
like Nickelback hate.
You know what I mean?
Hang on a second.
Is fucking curtains messed up.
It's driving me fucking crazy craziness.
Stare at it the entire time.
What is the problem?
There we go.
Sorry.
I apologize.
Yes.
So,
so cold play comes out.
I don't know what they were singing.
They were jumping around a lot.
I immediately left cause I didn't want to watch Beyonce Sass it up.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
I,
I cannot,
the same way,
you know,
the way she behaves on stage as a way a lot of athletes behave after they make a
great fucking play in somewhere that,
that happened during my lifetime.
It went from fucking scoring a touchdown,
just giving the ball to the ref to absolutely.
You know,
just fucking,
I dunno what you do.
You start line dancing and you just can't believe how amazing you are.
Right?
And everybody claims,
oh,
he's having so much fun.
No,
he isn't.
He's marketing himself.
He's hard himself out right now.
All right?
You should literally have to put on a pair of fucking stilettos when you do it.
Just walk the fucking block after you fucking dunk or score a touchdown or
whatever.
Right?
So I didn't want to watch her,
you know,
you know that fucking stupid walk the divas do.
They sort of stomped down the stage as they cross one leg over in front of
[inaudible].
Hey,
hey,
swinging their fucking hips.
I always just want somebody to just give them a big fucking leg sweep.
That's me.
You know what I mean?
So it's like,
I don't want to watch that shit.
So cold play comes up and everybody says,
Ah,
God,
Jesus Christ,
he's,
you know,
no one wants to see him.
It wasn't that bad,
but I could feel it.
You know,
I just want to say,
you know,
I don't understand these fucking bands that sell millions and millions of
fucking records yet.
You cannot find one person that will admit that there were fan.
Right?
All you guys right now who are nodding your heads going,
oh yeah,
they're so fucking lame.
Scroll through your fucking phone right now.
Go to the seas,
go down to see.
Oh,
you're going to find you got one song admitted you got,
you must have what song,
right?
What's that one?
The first hit I was like,
oh,
it's fine.
Look at me face as I walked down
the beach
with all with thing
and it was all yellow.
I married a chick,
she had yellow hair.
I didn't wear [inaudible] and I'm still pay and Chad supports.
Does he pay child support to her is,
yeah.
The other way around.
That's a close one.
It's the name of that broad dad that he married.
Huh?
She looks fucking moody.
All those good looking chicks at do fucking yoga.
They're damn fucking basket run in the other directions,
you know?
And they had like those stones that are for the CI and they put them around the
fucking house and I think they think that makes them spiritual.
You just gotta get the fuck away from him.
You know,
anybody with a yoga room and is at least an eight as far as being good looking.
You just gotta get the fuck away from there.
They're too good looking to be spiritual,
you know what I mean?
He's never had to buy a drink for yourself in your life.
I don't give a fuck how much yoga you do.
You're not going to be able to have any sort of self analysis,
you know,
like I don't think the thought of,
you know what I mean?
Maybe I was being a cut there.
I don't think that ever fucking goes through your head.
Um,
so I got to commend that guy and Coldplay for not writing a lot of angry songs.
He just Kinda has like,
does he just have nice sign?
I think that's what I think that's a big problem with that band.
It's just nice,
right?
We sync
generally in a good mood,
male.
The guy seems like a happy guy that makes you pretty hateable.
You know what?
Anybody you put on a fucking flannel jacket,
right?
Dress like a lumberjack.
You know,
mocking that hard work as you go fucking sitting around it and your goddamn m
and m's in your green room,
you come out and you send some sinks,
a miserable song.
Everybody likes you.
All right?
The is that guy's name.
They're saying all those songs.
Okay.
Ugh.
Nirvana.
Right.
That Cook Kobe.
Matt.
Yeah.
I really wish he didn't kill himself so I could trash it more.
You know,
fucking guy.
I wish I was like,
you know,
easily amused.
Hey Corey,
you don't fucking know me.
Go Fuck Yourself.
They fuck you think I'm doing staring at a drain all over here.
All amazed that it keeps spinning.
Yeah,
I ain't did shit.
Came out.
It was like,
this just isn't me.
Or was this guy the most condescending kind of sending can't ever,
he comes out there first fucking video.
He's making fun of tap on Solos.
Like he could do it.
He just didn't feel like doing it.
Yeah.
Sorry.
This,
this is just the ramblings of a man who's Wa who saw the beginning,
the middle and the end of hair metal,
and he took it all seriously
and that God damn Nirvana,
I just sounded like Giamatti and then fucking Howard stern movie.
Howard Stern.
Yeah.
God Damn Mother Fucker Be v Meme.
Derosa rewound that like 15 times.
You know when the end of the movie when like pig vomit careers just completely
in the shitter and he's like standing outside.
He's just dumbfounded at the success that Howard's head.
He's just how it started.
He just kind of looks away at God damn motherfucker.
Anyways,
I'm just saying,
you know,
how about in 2060
there's so much,
so many real things out there to get your passion up,
up about.
I don't think he should go around hating Coldplay.
Oh that poor bastard.
It poor bastard got married to a beautiful woman that did yoga.
Oh my God,
it's over.
It's fucking over
some those self-involved fucking human beings you're ever going to find in your
life are going to be in that fucking stinky ass yoga room,
you know?
Speaking of which,
I'm probably going to take a class this week
now.
My wife,
she stayed with it man,
seven days in.
She's going to try to do yoga this whole fucking month.
Right.
And uh,
she actually asked me,
I can't remember if she asked me on the podcast,
but she asked me,
she goes,
you want to go to one of my yoga classes?
And I was like,
no.
I was like,
I'll do yoga.
But I liked doing it here at the house,
you know what I mean?
Where like if I feel like stopping doing yoga,
I can just hit pause on the audio,
you know,
go out and have some cereal and then come back and just immediately fast forward
to the closing poses.
Right.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I just hate how when you fucking go in there,
they act like they have just the keys to happiness all the time,
you know?
And there's not one picture of anybody on the wall.
You know what these testimonies going like,
you know,
I was a really miserable cunt and then I went down and I took fucking Sally
Struthers Yoga class here and I don't know,
she was just rambling and I was in down dog and all of a sudden it just clicked.
And I have been so happy ever since,
you know,
I'm not saying yoga is overrated,
I just don't need the fucking,
I don't need the chatter from the instructor.
Just tell me the next fucking post to do it.
Tell me to breathe.
Okay.
Stop with your,
with your God damn philosophies.
You ever watch a cooking show and they just get off on these fucking tangents.
It's like,
well,
you just tell me the next ingredient.
I don't even where Bazell comes from and how they used to bring it over.
And wooden ships.
I don't give a fuck.
Right.
It comes from actually comes from Bazell Romania,
which is how it got its name.
Um,
do you know the amount of people that are actually going to fucking waste of
time tweeting me that there's no such thing as Bazell Romania,
you know,
is if I don't know that that city is not in Italy.
Um,
the,
when somebody did to me the other day,
they,
I talked so much shit on this podcast.
Like when people give me shit for stuff that I say half the time I can't
remember what they're talking about.
So somebody tweeted at me twittered at me and said,
uh,
they said,
you know,
I guess I supported something.
Okay.
For whatever reason they,
they took my rambling seriously and,
and they said,
yeah,
ah,
supporting blah blah,
blah.
Is it something,
do your homework next time you support blah,
blah,
blah.
Right.
And then had a link,
see?
Right,
right out of the gate,
I'm always like,
who the fuck is this fucking asshole coming at me with that tote?
Okay,
yeah.
Do your homework.
Like I work for you.
You can't.
Right.
So he goes,
do your homework and whatever I said about something,
his could is his fuck.
His homework was,
he sent me a link to an article in the New York Times so that,
that was his homework.
He fucking looked at one periodical that leans completely one way politically
right.
The old liberal fucking New York Times.
So like,
and I'm actually,
I feel like I'm a liberal.
Right.
Well,
I would never just read the New York Times and just be like,
well there you go.
That's every damn week.
What's happening?
Okay.
Do you know dumb that is,
that would be like listening to this podcast and taking it seriously and
wasting,
it's fucking three minutes.
She love to tweet me.
Jesus built,
did you bring it all back around your fucking old school?
Cont maybe I did.
Maybe I did.
How about von Miller?
Huh?
You ever see a more deserving fucking MVP?
He just,
he mugged Cam Newton.
He came right in fucking Cam Newton back to pass.
Give me that fucking thing.
Right.
Just ripped it right out of his fucking heads.
Um,
having said that,
I think,
uh,
I think Cam Newton is actually going to definitely going to be back and he's
going to win.
Win a ring and I,
I said that,
I tweeted that and everyone's okay.
[inaudible] right.
Their default fucking quarterback to shit on.
MMM.
Cam Newton actually has a fucking running game.
He actually has receivers.
He actually has a fucking unbelievable defense and a fucking contemporary coach.
Dan Marino had none of those things.
He had the receivers duper and Clayton.
Right.
Other than,
I'm not going to go through this again.
Okay.
Just look up the fucking look up running backs from 1983 to 1999 during k Derryn
uh,
Dan Marino's fucking career.
I told you Delvin Williams,
Tony,
Nathan,
Kareem Abdul Jabbar,
the football player,
he never,
he never had his Edwards and James is Tony doors setting and he never had that
man.
Never had that shit.
Okay.
I'm not saying Cam Newton has that,
but he has enough of a fucking team around it.
Whatever.
Keep talking shit.
You wait.
Cam Newton will be back.
He needed that as a youngster.
He had to feel that fucking awful.
This is what it feels like to lose this fucking game,
you know?
Okay.
You watched the next time he goes out there,
he's going to fucking,
uh,
I don't always get to do it,
Bill.
You don't know what the fuck he's going to do.
Your guests,
the guests,
and you guessed,
all right.
Last year you thought Seattle was going to win in the fucking patriots when Yo,
you will.
You've taught your own fucking team was going to lose.
All right,
let me read a little bit.
Advertising.
Let me stumble through some advertising.
Here is I attempt to read out
loud.
Um,
all right.
With the fuck.
Are we all right?
Oh,
this isn't it.
here we go.
All right.
Oh Jesus.
Here it's that time of year.
It's that time a year when you can say,
get me some chocolate covered strawberries.
Sherry's berries,
every body.
Oh,
this stupid fucking holiday.
Valentine's Day is just a couple of days away.
Ah,
where are you and your relationship that you're actually nervous that you have
to fucking get your broad something.
I want to be nice if he,
I'm not even read the copy.
You want to be fucking Nice.
If you could just click on something and you guys,
you're fucking,
you know,
you know what von Miller rip the ball out of Cam Newton's hands.
What if you could just put a box,
you could do the exact opposite.
The football is far box of fucking candies,
right?
And rather than ripping it out of her hand,
you just place it in there.
Or maybe Sherry's berries is Cam Newton.
You go give me that fucking thing.
Right?
And he just frisbeed over to your wife.
Girlfriend.
A Gulf.
Huh?
What'd you get Mick?
Yeah.
Nothing right?
Where'd you get high?
New Thumb.
Oh Gee,
thank you.
Where'd it go out of your wake?
Um,
Bella.
High stakes.
Just a couple of days away.
Everybody is and there's only one way to win valentines to win.
Okay.
Jesus Christ is the way that I resent this copyright now that I actually tap to
talk to my male listeners here,
like they have to dance for their women ladies,
by the way,
why don't you get you,
once you get your man a box of chocolates,
I should do it.
You a fucking box of chocolates.
You just give a little fucking little pitch of the cheek there.
Hey,
you go to QUT.
Um,
there's only one sure way to have to win on Valentines this year and that is to
win her heart all over again with a box of chocolates.
Jesus Christ health.
What is the reading level of the woman you're with?
It all is going to cost us some chocolate covered strawberry.
Tell a personal story related to Valentine's Day.
Well,
I think it's a complete bullshit holiday.
All right.
I resent the fact that there's some sort of pressure put on me that I'm supposed
to fucking do something for her because there's no day that the lady has to do
some for me.
Alright,
so fuck you.
When your strawberries,
you have to show some hard to win.
And Sherry's berries knows exactly how.
Make sure to get it right this year with romantic,
fresh,
juicy berries from Sherry's berries.
To be honest with you,
this is really all anybody deserves on a phony holiday is you just fucking
click,
click and shoot.
There you go.
You know when she's not looking,
you eat more than she does.
Giant freshly drip dipped strawberries were Sherry's berries starting at just 20
bucks.
Oh,
here you go.
One $20 bill.
I'll throw that down.
Over 40% savings.
And for my listeners and anybody else where they advertise in the universe,
you can get double the barriers for just 10 bucks.
Just go to Barry's dot com click on the microphone and type in the code burr.
These strawberries are picked at the peak of freshness to ensure the best gift
experience.
Yeah,
I was kidding.
Julia Yanka when there's still green and they ripen on the truck dipped in
white,
milky dark chocolate.
He goodness.
Just like bananas,
a top with chocolate chips,
decorative swivels or nuts.
Delivery is always guaranteed.
Even on Sunday is the only way to get these amazing Valentine's Day d day deal.
Uh,
visit Barry's Dotcom.
Please spell out the word Barry's,
B e r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone in the top right hand corner,
but the page type in Burger or the berries.com.
Click on the microphone and the code.
You might sorta today,
uh,
time is running out.
Exclamation point.
Look,
if you want to get some fucking chocolate's just get her some chocolates.
You know what I mean?
Um,
you know what?
I've actually waited too long.
This a fucking place in South Dakota that has like the best fucking deadwood
that has some of the most insane fucking chocolate you're ever going to get.
You know,
you could do that,
but it's too late now.
So just to remember that for next year.
Okay guys,
if you want to win her heart back a pro flowers,
Valentine's Day is this weekend.
Oh God,
here we go again.
Only x x days away.
I love what they think I'm going to do in the math.
Uh,
six days away I did a foyer.
Ah,
tired of guessing wrong what she wants each Valentine's Day.
See you see what's in that copyright there.
Oh yeah,
she didn't like you got her a gift and what?
She didn't like it.
So then what?
She didn't blow you.
Jesus Christ.
Why does it use crank one of those music grinders and you dance around with the
little monkey head on this.
This is,
I don't like any of the sh or Valentine's Day pro flowers and pro flowers.
They here to take the guesswork out of it.
Yeah,
and couldn't case you couldn't figure out getting a flowers Valentine's Day.
Trust the experts it pro flowers.
Who gives you the confidence that Valentine's Day is done right?
Pro Flowers is offering my listeners and anybody else in the universe.
It doesn't.
Red Roses plus a free vase,
glass vase and chocolates for just 29 99 then moving in on Sherry Barry's turf
or really do it right in upgrade to the romantic long stem roses with a premium
vase chocolates and a spa kit for Knight.
Knight.
Knight does nine 99 sorry,
go to proflowers.com and use my code birth.
So I was just thinking it's any worse when a woman tries to be sexy and she
isn't.
She puts a long stem roses and she tries to do that.
Beyonce divas,
stomp over towards her.
You know,
she looks like she had some season in physical therapy.
A don't wait until this weekend.
Send them Namdar
this week when a coworker's gush over her gift.
You know you did Valentine's Day,
right PLO,
fraught PLO,
flowers as quick,
easy and delivery for Valentine's Day as guaranteed pro flowers are guaranteed
the last seven or your money back.
It's a no brainer.
Like he'd give a shit after five days.
Kay.
Beat the price and convenience.
Proflowers takes the care of the DTA.
Go to proflowers.com click on the blue microphone in the top right hand corner
and type in burpee you are.
That's proflowers.com click on the microphone and type in my code,
burr flowers and chocolates.
There you go.
Shashi Goddamn fucking Keiko full the next Guardium year.
All right,
I'll read the rest of these leader,
um,
who
may phase sag Archie's flowers and a box of chocolate and your wall blow me.
What the fuck do I have to fucking do?
What the fuck is the rest of my shit here?
I just don't,
I just don't understand where it goes.
Where the fuck does it go?
It should be right behind and it always just disappears.
This is really an annoying me.
Oh God.
Is that another fucking celebrity on the God damn stump for a political
candidate?
Why?
Why does celebrities do that?
That just makes me not want to vote for the person.
Oh look,
the creator of teenage mutant Ninja Turtles is going to tell me why I should
vote for fucking
now that fat guy,
New Jersey,
whatever the fuck his name is,
he's got to have an agent.
His name,
like if I was on wheel of fortune,
I just looked at his name.
For some reason,
age seems like a fat guy named,
you know Husky Hash fat people lead Hash.
You know what I mean?
You know,
you know what it's like a mystery meat and they just fucking scramble an egg on
top of it.
You know it's funny,
I eat hash.
Is that as fucking is that are a side piece meal or is that a fucking side me or
whatever the fuck he call it.
Side dishes.
Hash is side dishes that have fucking,
and I have no idea,
so many fucking meals.
When I was growing up,
um,
I found later we're side dishes.
Like when I was growing up,
Mac and cheese was an entree.
My mother would just make a big fucking tray of it and then she'd make some
toast and it was the shit,
the Kraft macaroni and cheese.
It was frozen,
right?
She did the old right there.
Fred through it.
The fucking
through right in the fucking stove,
right.
Made it like Golden Brown on top.
She take it out,
scoop it out.
It's the Gilner fuel your shield the fuck out of my face,
right?
A little bit.
Toast,
right.
Buttering the toast the way old school moms did every fucking inch or the God
damn piece of toast
and at least,
you know,
at least a quarter stick of fucking butter on it.
You know,
remember all those fucking meals from the 70s chicken,
Allah king chipped beef on toast.
I've talked about this before.
I haven't,
I green bean casserole was just mushroom soup and they threw fucking green beans
in it.
Just heated it up
and it was a fucking worst man.
I Hate Green Bean casserole.
I always had a strategy that was either beginning or end.
Anytime it was green,
I was either getting it out of the fucking way or I was just going to put it off
like a term paper.
I swear to God to this fucking day,
man,
it took me a long time to every eat like mushroom soup.
Good.
You know Paul Versey thinks mushrooms are useless.
Tell that to the druggies,
man.
He doesn't like mushrooms.
He doesn't like corn and he doesn't like peace.
How do you not like peas man?
There's something fucking wrong with you,
right?
You've got five if you've got mashed potatoes right,
that are made right.
Okay.
And then you take the fucking Dispo I and your mush it down and then you'd take
a big clump of butter even though you already put buttering,
you'd drop it on there.
You put salt and pepper on that and then he got some peas right next to it.
The Fuck Outta here.
Paul Versey.
What do we hang out with?
Deca?
How did you hang out with somebody that doesn't like peas?
You know,
God helped that bastard.
If he ever goes to fucking Scotland,
you know,
they're mushy peas.
Um,
anyways.
Anyway,
what the fuck I'm talking about here?
Um,
you know,
I got my car all fixed up,
right?
Got It all fixed up,
got all the dense taken out of it,
and I fucking backed into something yesterday.
Not hard by something.
I mean somebody else's car.
Not Hard,
but hard enough.
I just put a couple of hack marks.
I didn't do anything to their car.
They of course had a fucking SUV,
so,
you know,
they're like a dentist or something and it had like this,
this fucking license plate holder thing that just dug right into my bumper.
So it's already a little hacked up.
But,
uh,
I dunno,
you know,
it's funny.
Ever since I the Prius,
right?
I used to be really good at backing up and ship and ever since the yet like that
backup camera,
like I find myself not even looking anymore,
I become worse salad.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
It's like when you start delegating power,
you've ever job.
He just started delegating power.
Then all of a sudden you just sit behind your desk and you're like,
I really had nothing to do here.
And then you look up and there's your superior standing there in the doorway.
Uh,
what are you doing today?
He had started shuffling some papers and the casino you get laid off,
right?
You just delegated enough fucking bar.
That's what I've done with that,
that backup camera.
I've delegated so much of my fucking census to make sure I don't run over
somebody.
I really shouldn't say this because if I ever fucking hit somebody,
how bad would that be if they played my own podcast and court?
Right?
Ah,
you Ron.
How are we like to submit into evidence?
A Gibby day,
the podcast
from a February the eighth,
2016 where he clearly states that demand does not even look behind his calf when
he backs up.
Clear.
What's a matter?
It's a matter of buddy.
Do you know I,
um,
somebody who's here,
who's here,
who share Cleo?
Okay,
you want to eat somebody?
Okay.
You're wagging your tail though.
You never know.
All right buddy.
Relax.
Now they got you all amped up,
huh?
Nia?
Is there somebody here?
Yeah.
It was funny about being married.
Aside from the fact that you've got a whisper on your own podcast sometimes just
to make your day easier.
It's just the ups and downs,
you know what I mean?
You could see it and your wife's eyes some days she knows why she marries you,
married you.
And then other days she's like,
what the fuck did I get to my wagon to?
And I know it's early.
I know it's early in the day,
but I'm feeling like it's going to be one of those.
What the fuck did I marry day?
[inaudible] get up here.
Come here.
Get up here.
Come on.
How are you buddy?
Huh?
Leon,
could you lay down?
Thank you.
Jesus.
Do you do anything easy?
Dude,
the fucking thing just collapses down on me.
Um,
we'll do your homework,
man.
All right,
let's,
uh,
let's read a couple of questions here for this week.
Was anything else?
Oh,
I know why,
but I was talking about celebrities
talking about fucking candidates.
It's like,
why the fuck do you think I need?
Like I'm undecided and then like the guy who created jag comes on TV or like one
of the stars,
you know,
they were always out there fucking I.
Oh,
what do they do?
What are you doing?
You're an actor,
you're a writer.
The fuck do you know about running the country?
Shut up.
Shop ruining the candidate that I like.
Right?
I like Bernie Sanders because he reminds me of an old fucking club owner that I
had.
And when he get,
when he gets mad and he starts screaming and yelling,
this is clip of him yelling at Alan Greenspan when he was running the Federal
Reserve and it's a classic fucking clip,
put it on the fucking Internet.
There were like Bernie Sanders takes to fucking,
you know,
whatever the fucking guy from,
uh,
the,
the big bank there.
I just said it.
Federal Reserve.
Yeah,
it takes him to task,
right?
So he's reading the Guy,
the riot act and it's just amazing clip.
And right when it goes for the other guy to respond,
the fucking thing ends.
It's like,
well,
I want to hear what the other guys said.
Why am I yelling this week?
I want to hear what the other guys says.
You know
what kind of a fucking dope just watches that clip and then doesn't try to find,
okay.
You know what the guy from the Federal Reserve said,
okay,
right.
The I should at least be able to,
to,
you know,
point counterpoint.
It's Kinda like that country who sent me that thing,
like,
go do your homework.
He just sends me the thing from the fucking New York Times,
liked the New York Times,
but I would never just read something that they said and below.
Well,
there you go.
Shit,
Joe.
I need to know.
Isn't that right Cleo?
We'll exhale into the mic.
I've been really doing really good about keeping my energy low,
trying to around the dog.
Um,
to get it to be a little more,
a little more mellow.
Yours.
Try and do eat the guess,
um,
my torch and you guys with the fucking thing.
You know what?
That's the only Coldplay song I know.
Okay.
I know there's some other ones.
I go see those guys and concert,
you know what I mean?
Watching some soccer moms.
Losing their fucking minds.
Huh?
Doing some fucking dance moves from the fucking,
well wait a minute.
They are actually be younger than me.
The hell am I talking about?
I think I need to shut the fuck up.
You know,
I think in general,
I think general bill.
Thank you gentlemen.
You might need to shut the fuck up.
Um,
no,
I'm actually psyched because a,
I was trying to write this thing and I just kept procrastinating.
Right?
Cleo?
I'll see ya.
Um,
I kept procrastinating.
I finally just said fuck it.
And uh,
I just broke it down into three segments and over the course of like four days I
was able to finish it and now it's fucking done.
And it's like this giant weight off my chest and I don't have to do shit today.
And uh,
Oh,
you know what I'm going to do today?
I'm actually bringing my truck over my old truck.
I,
I found this,
um,
this spare tire assembly,
you know,
a lot of them don't have it.
Um,
at least my didn't have and I was able to find it.
It was off this guy's f two 50 that he was going to fix them.
I just kept offering him money for it.
He goes,
Nah,
I don't wanna get rid of it.
And I'd finally way overpaid for an I got it and they a powder coated it,
whatever the fuck that means to match.
It didn't match my truck and everything.
So finally I'm actually going to have a spare tire underneath the fucking thing
the way it's supposed to.
And I'm like,
that's my fucking day.
That's all I got to do today.
You know,
why?
Cause I sat down and I got that fucking thing done.
Although the door locks and Mike fucking house,
I still haven't done,
I bought the shit premium paint remover and a poxy remover or whatever the fuck
that is.
I got my little brush.
I'm going to try and get that fucking lockout today.
Cause I told you I got this old ass house,
as I mentioned a zillion times.
And I want the,
the interior door locks to work because I think it would be fucking hilarious if
when I left one time,
if I locked all the fucking doors in the house and then somebody broke into my
house in every fucking room,
they had to like try to break down another door.
They just go to Turner.
They just like,
fuck man,
it's doors locked.
Let's go around the other side.
Fuck,
you know,
10 minutes in,
they're not even trying to be quiet.
And we were like,
dude,
what the fuck the fuck is this guy?
And I didn't it.
Right.
And then,
then he goes in and I just have,
you know,
a bunch of fucking hats and teach free tee shirts from fucking comedy shows.
You know,
there's such an intelligence to just not having really anything of value in your
house.
You know what I mean?
I got a couple of fucking like antique tables and shit like that stuff that I
kind of liked.
But who the fuck's gonna steal that little cat burglar coming out with a fucking
table on his back.
You know,
they liked the fucking,
they liked the little shit and they'd come in wearing their yoga pants,
right.
Rappelling down from the fucking roof.
I didn't think it would be hilarious.
Who's getting hold the,
the ultimate thing is,
is that you had like security in your fucking house,
right?
And somebody comes in,
And they get to that certain point.
I know I've seen this in movies and they'll all of a sudden there's just that
metal thing comes down so then they can't leave.
Just
frighten the sitting there fucking panicking.
You know what I mean?
I always thought that that would be great.
And then like I was thinking like eating like a giant room,
right?
When they're in the living room or some shit.
Like all of a sudden they can't fucking get out and they're freaking out.
And then they're just sitting there and they think worst case scenario is that
the cops had shown up and they're going to get fucking arrested and they kind of
mentally giving themselves into that.
And then you just like,
you have like a Cobra,
right?
And he just fucking let it in the room.
You know,
generally speaking,
those things out that fast to just have it just,
just,
maybe you defang the fucking thing.
Well,
that's not,
that's cruelty to animals.
Right?
But it's a reptile.
They're not really animals.
Right?
Um,
no,
you don't.
You just let the fucking thing come in,
coming to show in the hood.
Nobody can fucking hiss like a goddamn reptile man.
You ever go to those alligator farms?
Are you down in Florida?
You know what I mean?
And you're the,
first of all,
you're looking at the people go in there and you're like,
dude,
half of these people have murdered somebody and fed they're victim to one of
these fucking things.
I mean,
just Florida is just,
especially in the northern part of Florida,
I mean,
it just gets really fucking shady.
Um,
but when you hear those fucking things,
when they hated each other,
Jesus Christ,
I mean,
it just taps into back.
I get that to shit that's leftover from when you were a caveman.
You know what I mean?
Like,
just like,
I can't even explain it.
Like I went,
I was,
what the fuck was I?
I can't remember.
I went to a classic one,
two,
I think it was just outside of Tampa.
No,
maybe all of us are at the road in Miami or just south.
It's that one that has the alligator mouth that you will walk right into.
Right.
And I heard that thing fucking hiss.
And Dude,
from that tip of my head to the end of my toe,
tip of my toes,
the top of my head,
I fucked that up.
It just went just fucking like,
I can't explain the feeling,
just that,
that feeling when you lean back in a chair and you almost fall like my entire
body did that.
And the thing was way far away from me.
And I knew logically that it couldn't get to me.
But I still think that from all those years of when we just walked around living
in caves,
that your body's just still trained.
That if,
if it hears that fucking noise there reminds me when I saw three toed slough and
one time I was in Costa Rica,
right.
And we've taken the zip line tour.
Um,
it was like the most northern tip of,
of the fucking rain forest and the guide,
you know,
these fucking trees were unbelievable.
It was like,
we were like,
it felt like we were 150 feet in the air and we weren't even mid tree.
You looked up,
there was like another 300 feet above you.
It was fucking unbelievable.
It was a,
other than the fact that we were there,
you know,
doing a zip line tour and shit and had cell phones and stuff.
It was a fucking paradise.
So this guy did it every day.
So he knew where there's three toed sloth was and he looked up and he made this
noise of a,
I forget what the bird is called.
It's not an albatross,
but it does begin with an a and as a giant wingspan.
And they're not even in that area anymore because we killed all of them.
But to this day,
he imitates in the second he fucking imitated that thing.
The fucking three toed sloth just like got up and started fucking looking around
and then look down at us like,
dude,
what the fuck?
You know,
just be like,
don't,
don't do that.
It's not funny,
right?
Cause I guess those birds are so fucking big that they would swoop down into the
trees then with their talents.
They would just fucking just basically grab these fucking monkeys and just yank
him out of the tree and you're just completely fucked.
Jesus Christ,
those poor thanks man.
What a fucking way to go.
Can imagine me in that fucking slow.
Actually,
I can't,
I'm a classic White Guy.
Can't jump,
can't fucking run fast.
None of that shit.
Right.
Um,
doesn't understand dancing,
um,
by men anyways.
Um,
um,
that,
I don't even care if you're good at it.
I even care if you're good at it.
I just don't get it.
It just makes me laugh when I see a man dancing.
It just makes me fucking laugh.
I'm sorry.
It's really immature and I and I need to grow up when it comes to that,
but I'm just,
I'm just being honest.
So anyways,
I just can't imagine being that fucking thing.
Like it's slow and it's fucking awful as I am.
I just can't imagine if there was,
can,
you mentioned there's just some giant bird and you were on it's fucking menu and
you lived outside in fucking trees where birds are Jesus fucking Christ.
Any amount of time.
She just sitting there as a tree told sloths,
just chilling,
talking to a buddy of yours going like,
hey man,
what do you think in the next couple of days,
maybe a
no.
And your buddies sitting there talking,
he had be like
every like maybe like techstars date.
It's Thursday.
And I'll say,
this fucking thing just grabs your friend.
Yeah.
And do you think your friend is just fucking gone?
Okay.
Just gone.
You just see it disappeared.
What do a monkey doing
then?
You fucking
sitting here
like,
what the fuck?
Right.
Your heart racing.
Like he just did some blow.
But you only got the speed of a fucking three toed sloth.
Yeah.
Can you just sit there with the other three toed sloth doing what?
Just looking at each other like,
you know
that God,
that wasn't me,
but what the fuck?
Please make it quick.
Just fucking slice to things and neck already.
Sorry Matt.
He said a lot of empathy when I saw that the way the fucking,
it's almost like you had to see the fucking thinks face when he made that noise.
When he fucking looked around and looked down and saw that it was us,
he should've seen the look on this fucking thinks face.
He was just like,
I swear to God,
if it could just shit on us,
it would have,
and you know what?
We would've deserved it.
Well,
he's the guy who did.
It would've,
all right enough about three toasts.
Sloss let me,
uh,
beginning to fucking read in here.
Why don't we just have to fucking do this.
Tighten my fucking password.
Hey,
does anybody know how,
how do I get my computer to fucking link up with iTunes?
I actually watched a video on it.
The kids going,
yeah,
you go right over here and you click on this thing and it's like,
I didn't have that.
It must have a different version than him.
All right,
here we go.
Let's get into some of the reeds here or should I just finished with the
advertising?
Let's this Finnessey let's get the fucking bullshit out of the way first and
then we'll get into some of the questions for the week.
All right.
Uh,
he didn't put little flowers.
All right.
Oh,
dollar shave club.
Everybody,
you know,
lots of players will be sporting playoff beards now that the post season is
here,
they should really be done during,
in April during hockey season.
Um,
hockey playoffs,
the playoffs,
uh,
leave that to the pros kickoff your year the right way with a fresh blade shave.
That's why millions of other peoples have joined@dollarshaveclub.com.
Dollar Shave Club knows the key to getting an amazing shave is simple.
Use One fresh DSC blade to oh wait one,
use a fresh dollar shave club blades.
Sorry to use doctor cabbies.
Easy Shave.
That's it.
That's all you gotta do.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing razors right to your front door for a third
of the price of those greedy cunty mega razor corporations.
That means listeners who switched now can afford the luxury of shaving with a
fresh blade anytime and save hundreds this year.
And why when I was a child.
Yeah.
Your melt the blade for a month.
Uh,
and when you combine that fresh blade with their doctor cabbies,
easy shave butter,
it just glides.
It's unimaginably smooth.
I'm telling you,
it's not your average shave foam.
All right?
It's not gonna drive you skin.
The all natural ingredients will leave your skin feeling soft,
smooth and moisturized after every shape.
Take it from me.
A fucking cunt who doesn't read?
Use a fresh dollar shave club blade with doctor cabbies.
Easy shave butter.
Uh,
if you want the most gentle shave imaginable,
join the dollar shave,
joined dollar shave club.com/bird today.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr high dollar shave club.com/burr.
And lastly,
but certainly,
certainly not leastly blue apron.
All right?
You need to know how to cook.
You don't need to,
but I mean,
you're going to be in shape if you learn how to,
but you don't want to go to the grocery store.
You don't want to have to fucking deal with all of that shit,
right?
But you need to know how to cook.
Not only do you need a,
not only do you feel like you know your way around the kitchen,
but looking at big cooking at home,
slowdown pill,
but cooking at home,
it means eating healthier and saving money instead of ordering expensive takeout
again.
But where do you start?
Blue Apron and she covered for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all the fresh ingredients you need to create home cooked
meals.
Just follow the easy step by step instructions.
Each meal can be prepared in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the grocery store.
I can't deal,
man.
No more sad takeout.
No matter your dietary preferences.
Blue Apron makes it,
makes it a breeze to discover and prepare dishes like roast chicken,
supreme with mashed potatoes,
gravy and maple glazed carrots.
Spiced salmon with black rice,
avocado and blood orange salad.
I didn't know there was a such thing as black rice.
I knew there was brown rice or white rice,
right?
Caucasian and Latino,
right.
Uh,
me.
So horny me.
So honey,
roasted chicken and baby sweet potatoes was stir fried sesame.
Bok Choy.
I fucking love Bok Choy,
but only when I go to Korea town.
Every time I tried to make it a fuck it up and he cranes listening out there.
Korean Americans,
Korean Koreans,
South Koreans,
North Koreans,
Huh?
I wouldn't do that to you in North Korea.
I wouldn't do that to you.
Fucking bosses son.
There is not letting you have any food.
Right?
Steak Sandwich with Carl.
It's done.
Onions,
garlic,
Aioli and honey roasted parsnip fries,
Parmesan and provolone pizza.
We got it.
You got a lot of shit.
Tomato quiche where they supposed to read all of those delicious and food and
good for you right now you can get your first two meals for free@blueapron.com
slash bird that's blue apron.com/bar hey,
blue apron.com/burr.
Dude,
that's fucking great man.
Bring it right to your goddamn door.
Let's show you how to cook it.
You learn how to cook a little bit,
you know,
eat healthy.
Stomach is flat,
you know,
and next thing you know,
you get somebody to buy some fucking chocolate strawberries for.
All right,
let's get to the questions for this week.
Okay.
Trusting water.
Hey Billy,
filter face.
I like that one.
A don't trust drinking water.
I don't trust drinking water.
He goes,
my friends think I'm nuts.
They always point to the fact that public drinking water is tested time and time
again.
Now this Flint Michigan Fiasco,
uh,
its surface that officials lied about testing,
did slow drip tests from faucets in order
to get lower levels of whatever horse shit shouldn't have been there to begin
with.
And even wrote it off because most complaints weren't,
were coming from minorities to,
to how do you do that and go to sleep at night?
How do you do that?
How do those companies that do that?
Fracking,
and I'm not,
I'm saying I don't know anything about fracking,
but you know,
I've seen that in some cases it's fucked up to drinking water.
How do you not go?
Oh my God,
we fucked up.
What do we do here?
Oh my God,
we like sat a fucked up.
I'm the worst,
but I'm heading,
how do you,
I don't know.
I fuck you do it.
The best water comes in glass and is fresh from a natural spring.
That doesn't neighbor a dow chemical plant.
I stick to this as much as possible.
I know I'm not nuts.
I saw civil action with John Travolta in the theater once I saw,
oh,
he's about 20 years ago and it's haunted me since.
What's your level of trust when it comes to,
to water and what kind of water do you drink?
Thanks for the Thursday podcast.
Loved the music.
Uh,
that's Andrew Feminists.
Um,
go check.
Go check in on yourself.
All right.
Uh,
I dunno.
What does my feelings on it?
Yeah,
it's probably a scam or whatever.
I really feel that like,
I try to be as healthy as I can.
I have this weird thing where,
okay,
you know,
I'm trying to be healthy and live as long as I can.
While.
I also feel that like most people on earth dying would be a great thing.
MMM.
Cause I just think we're,
yeah,
we're just putting too much stress on all the,
on the natural resources.
I believe that personally I do now have I read enough?
No.
Do I know what I'm talking about now?
It's just what I do.
What you guys do.
I get a little bit of information and I just run with it in my brain.
Um,
and then someone reprimands me on fucking Twitter.
Do you homework me?
And um,
I actually had an acting gig with one person one time and they,
they,
they actually got their water delivered.
Um,
and rather than being in those giant plastic fucking things that you've got to
tip upside down,
they actually were in glass.
Um,
which,
who,
anything tastes better in a glass.
It always does.
Beer in a bottle tastes better than beer in a can.
Personally,
I feel it does.
Um,
but as far as where they get the water,
I don't think it matters as long as they fucking treat it right.
Does it?
It can't.
I don't know.
I don't fucking though,
I have no idea.
I try to drink water as much as I can when I'm not fucking booze and,
but uh,
no,
I don't have any faith in anything anymore.
I,
I don't,
I went to this little fancy fucking pet store today to get my dog some food and
they were like,
are you in our system?
And I'm like,
no,
I'm not.
And they go,
okay,
just so you know,
whenever you want to be in the system,
will you get a 5% discount every time?
And I just want to be like,
yeah,
and what do you get out of it?
What do you out of it?
You know,
you sell my fucking information to somebody and they'd say,
Oh,
well no,
we don't.
Well,
I know you don't.
Why would you do that?
Why would you just give me a 5% fucking discount forever?
That means you read them.
Marking the shit up is no fucking way.
Nobody goes out of their way to fucking make 5% less on some shit,
you know,
forever.
I could say,
hey,
we're having a sale.
You get people in there,
hey,
they kind of get used to go into the store and then you phase it out.
You get 5% off every fucking time.
You know,
I think being a paranoid con works.
It really does.
Except sometimes in relationships it isn't.
I said he was just a guy at the post office.
I gave him the mail.
Um,
all right,
turn up turn offs.
Hey Billy buttercups,
my friend and I were having a discussion about what turns us off about girls,
the usual gross things and physical appearance.
Things came up.
Uh,
I threw out.
I throw out there.
Yeah.
And I hate it when girls throw themselves at you with the disclaimer that if
you're,
if you're a quality,
if you're equally as into the girl,
it's not a problem.
What do you think about this isn't me or does it feel weird when a girl just
puts it all out?
That out there,
you said out that out there and starts casually mentioning her vantage cause she
thinks it's going to interest you as something.
Some of my friends thought I was nuts.
The other sort of agree.
Thanks and go crush yourself.
Um,
it all depends.
It all depends on the,
on the person,
you know what I mean?
Generally speaking,
if you just meet somebody,
you know and you have no idea who they are and they just start throwing
themselves at you,
you know,
and you look how I look,
you're like,
ah,
I don't think this is their first Rodeo.
It makes me nervous.
That would make me very nervous as far as like,
uh,
what's that beach?
Every song she's been around a Nova town oral cop.
You laid so no leader.
Um,
I would,
uh,
yeah,
I can see what that would,
that would freak you out.
But if,
um,
and how,
I don't know,
she's like in her thirties and she's just like,
look,
I'm,
and I'm not looking for a relationship.
You just want to kind of,
yeah.
Going to be fuck buddies area F yeah.
When I'm fucking,
that's what I do too.
I go,
yeah.
You know,
that always turns the ladies on.
Nothing gets them turned on.
Like cracking your voice.
Yeah.
Zev.
Um,
that just made me completely forget what I was going to say.
Oh fuck.
I had a funny story too.
God dammit
Baba Blah Blah.
Oh yeah.
You know,
I don't like when women try to be dominant
either.
You know what I mean?
They just,
I don't know.
They fucking,
they get on topic and they're like grabbing your wrists and they've got this
stupid look on their face and you just thinking like,
you know,
if I want it to I can just throw me off the bed.
Not for nothing.
But if you read through it,
um,
yeah.
I understand what you're saying here.
Uh,
if,
okay.
It's all how they do it.
If they just coming up confident their rent to you.
Yeah.
But if they just start talking about their fucking hoo ha.
A lot of it is the same.
It'd be like for a woman,
if a guy just came out,
he just flops his dick on the bar.
Ah.
Who wants it?
Come and get it.
Uh,
yeah.
I would think that would turn anybody off.
All right.
Global warming scam.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
Global warming scam.
Okay.
This is like a something that people keep sending me.
Um,
and they keep sending it to me as if my opinion,
it has any sort of scientific background.
I'm just basing it on scientist.
That's all I'm basing it on.
And that fucking two and a half times the size of Texas and two miles deep swirl
of garbage and the fucking Pacific Ocean.
Then how just about every fish has have some degree of plastic in there fucking
system.
Uh,
okay.
But even now,
but none of that has to do with temperature.
I love your show.
It's really refreshing to hear someone in show business actually talk about some
very important social pertinent things.
When the fuck do I ever do that?
Like what football?
Three toed slots
flopping your Dick on the Barth.
This,
these are important to you.
Um,
I agree with everything you talk about on your show.
I don't need you to,
he goes,
except or she says that he or she accept global warming.
The global warming scam is another system of control.
I agree.
We should stop using oil and coal.
These carbon sources are highly polluting and release toxins in mercury into the
biosphere.
But this has nothing to do with global warming.
I know you love documentaries at God.
Can,
can you guys just something my mom taking in a country way.
I know you love documentaries.
God knows you don't read.
No,
he's probably right.
Uh,
look up global warming swindle on Youtube.
A little taste in the global warming,
the global warming rat hole.
There's a ton of other information on the web that exposes this bullshit scam.
Good luck.
And looking forward to hear what you have to say about this.
See,
I don't get that.
I'm supposed to just look up a bunch of shit that all agrees with the other side
and then the other side's wrong.
That's like me saying to you,
look up all these shit about global warming and how we're affecting the climate
and I'm looking forward to see what you have to say.
Um,
I would think that,
uh,
okay.
The fact that in France,
all the leaders of the world just got together with all these scientists and all
that and even on the right they forward has been saying it's bullshit from day
one.
From day one,
they were saying it's fucking bullshit.
Um,
even they finally came out and they said,
yeah,
it's,
we are affecting it.
And then they were like,
but it's too late to do anything now.
Like that's what they came out with.
So why would they be doing that?
Why would they,
why we'll wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You're saying that they're doing it to try to control us and such a long way to
go isn't it
gave,
they just control this by scaring the shit out of us.
The normal way.
Like,
oh,
there's this group of people that doesn't have planes or a boat and they're
coming over here to get us like they'd been doing for 15 fucking years.
Can't they just do that?
Um,
I'll watch those things,
but I would like to know who paid for those,
who finance those documentaries.
Because if they're companies that are getting attacked for it,
you know,
there's obviously,
getting attacked for the pollutants that they're putting into the atmosphere,
then,
you know,
they could be going,
well,
we need to get this off of us by putting the real information out there.
But generally speaking,
I've,
I as a rule,
I don't believe corporations,
I just don't,
people in general,
I mean I'm fortunate,
right?
Why the fuck would I believe?
Uh,
I watch it.
You know what?
I hope you know what?
This is the thing.
I actually hope you're right because then again,
I'm a lot less guilt and just go out and buy some fucking
Goddamn v eight man,
get out there and fucking drive around.
Do some doubts.
A PS,
global warming carbon credits are controlled by the same crooked bankers that
are fucking up the world economy.
Well,
I kinda think like the bankers don't,
they control everything.
They kind of own everything,
right?
Are we still making payments on the White House?
Do they have to refinance that?
And I know it burned down in the 18 hundreds who knows?
I'm new girlfriend.
Bullied by friends.
Girlfriend.
Okay,
so you're new chick gets bullied by
WHO's friend?
Why?
I guess I got to read it.
All right.
I wanted your advice on something minor yet difficult for me to figure out on
how to approach.
I've just done pretty well for myself.
Getting a beautiful girl recently,
like she's physically attractive and has an ass I could balance a beer on.
Good for you.
Anyway,
our friend,
our friend group has a pretty good size even though some of our friends have
moved 30 minutes to an hour away,
but a problem came up recently.
A friend of mine from out of town recently came by with his girlfriend and after
a night out of drinking,
my girlfriend informed me his girlfriend bullied her and treated her like shit
in high school.
All right,
well that was a long time ago.
Well that's the next thing he goes.
I told her that was a long time ago.
That's what I want to say.
He goes with 26 and that
she shouldn't,
should try to approach her to which she replied that when the girl in question
said hello to me,
she looked at her and just walked away.
Totally.
That was a long time ago.
Wait,
wait.
And that she should approach it to which my girlfriend implied that when the
girl in question said hello to me,
she looked at her and just walked away.
Wait,
who walked away?
Then when the girl in question said hello to me,
dude,
I don't know who's saying what here.
She also told me her high school was quite small and the girl in question and
many others made it hell for her.
Here's my question for the freckled Fucko of La.
How would you approach this situation?
Keep in mind,
I'm not the best of buds with the dude.
We're just in the same friend circle.
Well,
what happened?
You're 26 you're probably going to see her like what?
Once every couple of fucking weeks.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't think it's a problem.
Okay.
I would just look at her,
just be like,
Hey,
can you stop fucking making a big deal out of nothing,
uh,
before you stick your fucking head and I stick it in the cupboard or you start
bullying or,
I dunno what I would do.
I would just be like,
um,
okay.
Yeah.
How would you say looking at 26 years old?
High school ended eight years ago.
Um,
I just let it go because she doesn't give a fuck.
Bullies never remember the shit that they did to you and she's probably jealous
because you beautiful with an ass.
She could balance a drink on right now.
It's probably what it is.
Okay.
I Dunno.
In the meantime,
while you take some,
a Jujitsu classes.
Alright,
we'll Israeli a fucking martial arts.
I always want to take that shit.
You know,
a little Jujitsu and then that fucking Israel,
whatever the Israeli martial arts shit is the fuck is that shit called.
I don't even fucking know.
I always just start like that shit.
It's just like,
you know,
because of the level,
the stakes going on over there.
Like this just is,
no,
I guess they're all a fish.
I don't know fucking shit about fighting,
but I was just felt like that that would be the shit,
you know,
just because of where Israeli is and how they never have planes get hijacked or
anything.
They just got shit on lock down.
You would think that their martial arts would,
they would be,
they would definitely be a lot of interesting,
I would think I gouging just fucking do you take your fucking index and your
middle finger and you just fucking,
they probably know how to do that.
That macgruber throat snatch thing,
you know,
snatching throats.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't know what to tell you.
I'm not,
I'm not good at that shit,
dude.
I,
if you haven't noticed,
I don't know a lot about women.
I really don't like I,
I grew up,
you know,
uh,
with way too many.
It was,
it not balanced,
you know what I mean?
It was not,
uh,
it was just fucking,
okay.
I don't know.
To this day,
it's still,
I mean,
I had all brothers for the most part and then the dog and that dog was a fucking
boy,
you know what I mean?
It was just total overload,
a testosterone and then my mom and we lived up on a busy street,
so we just all interacted with each other.
And um,
yeah,
this is one of those fucking,
this is one of those.
That's one of those chick moments where I'm just really bad.
I'm just like,
uh,
well did she try to punch you?
Did she ever beat you up before then?
Like what's the fucking problem?
Just tell her to go fuck herself.
Right.
You don't understand.
You know Canada at,
it's still frustrating.
I know,
I know.
It's not you.
I know it's not you.
I know you're trying and I appreciate that.
I just feel like,
and they start talking to me and I sit there and I'm nodding and I'm listening
and just over this shoulder,
there's a TV with a game on and I start looking at it and looking at them.
Yeah.
Start acting like I'm rubbing my forehead,
you know,
blocking their view of one of my eyes so I can look at the fucking TV.
I start doing that shit and then eventually I get busted and then they get mad.
You know what I mean?
Um,
anyways,
if you would like to donate to this podcast,
it's very easy to do.
It won't cost you any money.
It just cards.
She had an extra couple of clicks.
If the index finger,
you just go to [inaudible] dot com and you click on the podcast page,
does it link to Amazon?
Next time you want to buy something on Amazon,
you can do this.
She just click on it and I get credit for driving traffic to Amazon.
And what if you buy something?
They kicked me a couple of bucks or whatever.
And uh,
and then I used to kick it to this fucking charity.
The people sent me enough shit that said it was a scam.
So now I give it to saint Jude saying,
you Jay's.
Um,
that's what I try to do.
I give a portion of the proceeds.
Well,
what portion bill?
We talking like an NFL portion know way better than the NFL.
I take 10% and I throw it to the fucking to Saint Jude's.
All right.
That's pretty good,
right?
Considering fucking the NFL does,
what will they do?
Do like 3% of that hundred dollars Jersey and then they give it to the pink lady
so she can go out and get herself a pink Cadillac.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody once again,
congratulations to the Denver Broncos and Peyton manning.
It was so fucking great to see that guy go out of winter,
man.
Um,
I did not want to see him,
you know?
Okay.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
I just,
I didn't want to see him get,
fuck.
Anyone want to see me?
His fucking ass kicked.
They get on a Superbowl.
I really did not want to see that.
And I'm,
I could Dolan,
since the panther fans,
you know,
you guys had a hell of a season.
A river bolt.
Ron,
is that his name?
Someone's tweeting me said,
is that the best fucking nickname and sports?
I didn't even know the guy's name to be honest with you,
but I saw him on the sideline at one point the second quarter,
and I said to my buddy,
I go,
that guy looks like the winning coach of a super bowl.
Um,
that's what I felt like when I saw the guy.
So obviously you guys are going to be back a block of time.
She get there and you don't win it the first time and then you remember what
that feeling's like and then you come back.
Uh,
I dunno.
You guys should be all right.
You'll get one right?
Well it all Peyton Madec,
he fucking hung in there.
We got one.
John Elway came in there and this Denver's the fucking place to go for old
fucking quarterbacks to get one more.
What do you guys think?
Do you think he retires?
He should.
There's already rumors that he's going to be coming out here to the Los Angeles
Rams,
you know,
which you'd be very Joe Nemeth,
Joe Willie,
Joe Willie ended.
That's actually,
that's a good fucking quiz,
Huh?
He named hall of fame quarterbacks in teams that they ended with Joe name at the
end of what?
The rams.
Johnny John Unitas.
Johnny Unitas.
Andy with San Diego,
I believe.
MMM,
tired man.
Once you think once they fucking disappear and they go off the fucking radar.
Let's pick another one here.
Drew Bledsoe.
Who did he finish with?
Went to the bills.
Then he went to the cowboys and I want to say you went somewhere else.
Okay.
Brett Farve.
Where did he end?
Vikings.
Who was going to go to the vikings at the end of his career at the last second
said,
fuck that.
I'm not doing it and was a smart move.
I mentioned earlier,
Dan Marino,
Dan Marino had an offer and he said,
no,
fuck it.
I'm not doing it.
And what's great is all of his highlights.
He's wearing the dolphins uniform.
He doesn't have that sad,
you know the last team I fucking played for uniform.
Okay.
Emmitt Smith.
What did he finish?
Oh,
Arizona.
Yeah,
Franco Harris.
Okay.
Seattle Seahawks.
You know what?
I think I invented a good drinking game.
Might you just go through,
then somebody's got to look it up.
Then that means somebody knows all the answers.
You know what I think?
I just thought I had a great idea,
but I didn't.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll check it on Thursday.